[Music]
before we get into it can you just let
the people know what is a black hole
black hole is a region of space where
matter has condensed to such a high
density that the gravity at its surface
the surface gravity is so high
that you cannot escape it
even at the speed of light you are
forever trapped it is the
fabric of the space-time continuum
warped back on itself and once you fall
in you are never coming out it is the
human version of the roach motel
you check in but you don't check out a
black hole that's why we call them black
and when you fall and you don't come out
that's why we call it a hole
because we tell it like it is in
astrophysics black hole
spin that wheel
[Music]
daniel junius wants to know
what happens when we fall into a black
hole you want to avoid that first of all
never don't do that
neither at home or at work or anywhere
else but if you happen to fall in a
black hole which is my preferred form of
death
it's better than getting hit by a bus
right so if you've fallen in a feet
first dive
to this cosmic abyss
you will not survive
because you will not miss
the tidal forces of gravity
will create quite a calamity when you're
stretched head to toe
are you sure you want to go
those tidal forces
will increase to the point where your
body will just snap into
likely at the base of the spine
then each of those two pieces will snap
into two so you become one to two to
four to eight to sixteen until you
bifurcate all the way down
to the center of the black hole
and you become a stream of atoms and
that's not even the worst part
the worst part is you are funneled
extruded through the fabric of
space-time
so that you used to be this wide now
you're this narrow
and so
this phenomenon
this this
extrusion like toothpaste through a tube
we have a word for it
death by black hole is called
spaghettification
spaghettification sounds like a meal to
die for
see what i did there kill me we see all
this activity in the center of the
galaxy starts orbiting a big dark area
right how do we know it's not just like
the center of a hurricane and the reason
why we know that is because what we
learned from kepler and later newton
is the orbit that you have
is the speed of your orbit is completely
determined by the mass that's sitting
inside your orbit ah the mass around
which you
revolve right so what you say is here
are these things i can see how fast
they're moving
run back to kepler's equation and say
there must be a mass
a huge huge mass a huge mass like bigger
than the size of the orbit
wow wait and then you say but wait a
minute
we don't know anything that's that
massive
that's
smaller than the orbit except for
a black hole gotcha okay so in other
words if it was a star with that much
mass it would be huge or some other
thing and you'd see it you could see it
right i see a glowing thing this is dark
and it has huge mass
and it's small
that's three smoking guns right there
right implicating
a supermassive black hole
super massive black hole yes
and our black hole is less massive
than the one in the center the andromeda
galaxy our nearest big galaxy do we have
black hole envy well i think we do yeah
yeah
so but we're talking about hundreds of
millions of times the mass of the sun
but it's a black hole so it's small for
that much mass wow and so that's why oh
so so we do it for our galaxy then we do
it for a neighboring galaxy wait a
minute go ahead and we can't no other
galaxies are far away so ground-based
telescopes you can't see it so we scent
up hubble
and so we say well if we have it and
we're not really a special galaxy in the
in the universe and andromeda has it our
nearest neighbor
maybe this is astronomy astronomy think
these two galaxies have maybe every
galaxy
right okay because why should we be
special right it's called the copernican
principle you're probably not special
right
exactly copernicus better known as my
father
you're not so special
i don't know what you think but go ahead
your father interacting with you yeah
okay thank you so so you
we we hypothesize that maybe all
galaxies have black holes so you invoke
hubble who can see farther away galaxies
and measure the movements of stars down
deep in the middle and they were moving
fast too right and every next galaxy and
so we've now done enough
we're just resigned to the fact that
every galaxy's got to play even some of
the smaller galaxies that might not have
they got black holes they still have
black holes right so no we haven't seen
we haven't measured every one of the
hundred billion galaxies in the universe
but every galaxy we measured the big
ones the small ones it's like taking a
poll
yeah except even better right because
the universe doesn't
have weird people living in
back roads who think weird stuff
actually it might the universe could
have some weird galaxy that we've never
discovered before right every galaxy
that fits into a category of galaxies
that we've observed it's got a black
hole of different masses and the more
massive the the entire galaxy right then
the more massive the black hole is
that's you yeah there's some that have
billions of times the mass of the sun
has a black hole sitting in the middle
wow yeah
we got to stop for a second because i
gotta i gotta understand something here
i gotta understand something all right
okay all right so here's the deal
what you're saying is everything that is
chuck goes into the black hole so yeah
as
you want to reconstru recreate or
reconstruct the circumstance or anything
about me that
before i'm in there but now that i'm in
there okay
what comes out
which would be
the hawking radiation and the
evaporation of the black hole that's
what's coming out but what's coming out
is
really
nothing to do with it's not a
representation it's not coming out it's
not it's not a representation of me it's
materializing
as opposed to exiting and so since it's
materializing and as opposed to accident
then what comes out is not necessarily
related to
me that went in
it's even worse than that
oh sorry
[Laughter]
oh radiation you got me you got me i'm
like oh damn
the radiation was never inside the black
hole ever that's what i'm saying what's
happening it doesn't come out so what
happens is there are these little
quantum fluctuations that happen in
empty space okay that are allowed
because of uncertainty because
uncertainty says you cannot precisely
say a particle is there precisely
infinitely precisely you also cannot say
it's not there okay so is that the
uncertainty principle that you were
talking about
so that creates a possibility that
particles are just kind of created so
it's popping out of thin air oh wait
there's no errors
out of thin air then space spit thin
space thin empty space and what happens
is the black hole so they have to come
in pairs because if you think about
empty space it you know it has to be
also just completely bland and
featureless so i can't have an electron
appearing right because it has charge
and it has spin and it has all these
properties it has to come with a pair
that cancels its charge and it
neutralizes it completely we call it
neutralizing all its quantum numbers so
it has to come in pairs
and then it can go in and out of the
vacuum and just creates a kind of
quantum froth that we never notice wait
just to be clear that paired particle is
anti-matter right just to be clear so
right it would be an anti-matter
particle but you could also have it with
two photons or
two bundles of light which the photon is
its own anti-particle right oh my god uh
so the electron has a positron so
electron the positron can be created and
then disappear light can be created any
any particle that exists in the universe
has these fluctuations that we don't
notice it's happening in this room it's
just very very very low level we don't
know
but the black hole what it does is it
steals one of the partners doesn't
matter which one
it steals one of the pair and then the
other one can't go back to nothing
because it's not neutralized by its pair
it's just sits there so suddenly this
particle emmett leaves and comes out of
what seems like thin air thin empty
space and that's the hawking radiation
so it never originated inside the black
hole it was stolen so different what are
you saying wait however go ahead wait
wait wait wait wait wait oh my god this
is insane
that's why hawking was so famous because
it was like insane janet yeah janet
so
let me make things nice
i can't have chuck lose a brain gasket
here because i need him for other shows
okay
you said earlier at the beginning that
the event horizon is not some
wall
it's just space moves smoothly through
and across the event horizon you said
that correct okay
now the
curved space-time
shape
is made by the black hole correct yep so
every place that feels this curvature
is basically part of the footprint of
this black hole on the fabric of space
and time yeah so if i'm going to make a
hawking particle pair outside of the
event horizon from the gravitational
energy of the black hole itself
why won't you allow me to say i am using
the black hole identity to make this
happen i will allow you to say that but
the only identity the only feature
from outside the black hole this is why
the whole featureless aspect is so
profound the only future you can know
about the black hole from outside
because of the event horizon is its mass
its electric charge and its spin if it
spins like the earth
and those are the only three things you
can know about the black hole so that
any other information is occluded by the
event horizon all right so so you will
reflect in the radiation the mass the
spin and the charge but you won't
reflect that chuck fell in that his
scream
you know somebody's name okay so i can i
can reach that's gone i can reconstruct
his particles perhaps
you can't reconstruct even his quantum
no features about his quantum numbers
are knowable wait you're telling me
chuck has has 80 gazillion
neutrons made of quarks now
coming out the other side will i get
that same number of quarks
so the the hope is okay so so if you
just look at hawking's original
calculation he said no you won't and
that's what initiated the whole crisis
so wait a minute wait a minute because
quantum theorists said that's not
possible so and so
yeah if if what neil just asked is the
case and you're saying no
right then
are we saying that there's a that
there's a theft of information is there
a loss of information
that's that's what hawking suggested and
then it became this big fight so i would
say right now if you talk to people like
lenny suskind who has a great book um
called black hole wars where he talks
about trying to make the universe safe
from steven hogging
they would say they figured out a way to
encode the information the hawking
radiation so so i would say right now
the
hawking
um eventually kind of started to say
okay maybe you quantum guys are on to
something and maybe there's a sneaky
sneaky way
that the black hole emits information
but it's no mean feat and one of the
craziest suggestions for how the black
hole allows information to escape is to
say that there are wormholes that
connect the interior of the black hole
to the exterior of the black hole
so the hawking radiation which never
came from inside the black hole is
actually the the same particle
as lived in chuck's body
and it was navigated by a wormhole to
the output so it basically tunnels out
oh okay
okay so
it sounds like janet it sounds like yes
the same reaction that chuck did smash
guys we gotta fix this we can't we can't
live with this it's phenomenal let's
let's make something up let's pull
something out of our ass right let's
pull it pull a wormhole out of our ass
so that we don't have to blow our own
gasket that's exactly what happened but
it's actually
had really successful ideas so then you
start it gets even worse because if you
imagine all of these wormholes
entangling every single one of chuck's
particles with a particle on the outside
that means that neil you you or your
descendants could reconstruct from fire
what happened to chuck what he said what
his last moments were like but what also
we know we know what i said here's what
i said
that's what i said
[Laughter]
it's still fun to hear so so the
wormholes what they end up doing is they
create like stitching quantum stitching
so imagine like embroidery so imagine i
embroider an image of a black hole it's
really made up of tons of stitches and
when i look closely i realize that there
is no black hole there it's just made up
of tons of stitches and that's actually
one of the ideas that's coming out
that's most radical is that the black
hole is made
by these quantum entangled wormholes
that that is what the event horizon is
it is like cross-hatched quantum
phenomena and if i could see closely on
the quantum level i would realize the
black hole emerges as an illusion out of
quantum mechanics and that might be true
for all of gravity that it's actually
it's actually something that is
fundamentally
illusory
and really is just a quantum phenomenon
that we didn't recognize all this
because they didn't want to lose
information
what's what what sore losers they are
we
want to take another break
[Music]
you